volvo a tous en otras regiones perkosa
libya allahabad vous proposez anatra
interview exclusive ave conjure a
buceta antonio donec accusé affirmations ou
cetera chak fai oggi ami valo rua
anniversaire orteils encore plus tragédie
tresno VAR Danne être trié se supprimer
de la communication auto Dorado a
super hesperia  victime la familia sure
indecision no block ensalada y on a las
fritas je serai servi nu's a telephone
airport cuneta not opposition suj se produit
dans decision de nadie le publication
interview below can sue si compadre a
fat mob hello a tendre que tanto jit
tonello Viterbo  Daniel sur bein un
oculus volontaire sur CL Dulce Airport
Road se cacher sous un buceta doncha sur une
interview décidée de Matt Neal alors qu'il pour
les calibres de service la vie du DV public un
plaisir une vitesse faire Jo Lupo médecine
Danny sur le dcd que sur cactus mando
Bruce a  mer de lave pour traiter pas interviewer
exclusif Je deviens Jedi assailli un Papa do
main 06 oui je t'ai appelé ici aujourd'hui
parce que nous sommes confrontés à de graves circonstances  ances
nos renseignements ont confirmé l'
existence d'une nouvelle menace qui ne ressemble à
aucune de celles que nous avons vues auparavant, notre seul choix
d'action est de répondre à la force par la force à partir
de ce moment, mon programme est réactivé
et je passe le commandement de toutes
les opportunités de terrain mondiales Angela  bonjour
bonjour ravi de vous rencontrer première question dans
l'arc-en-ciel six voir pendant que vous jouez le rôle
de six femmes qui dirigent une unité
anti-terroriste d'élite pouvez-vous nous en dire un
peu plus sur votre personnage comme vous dites que
je suis le directeur adjoint et elle est  une très
forte présence imposante, vous savez, très
intelligente, elle est vraiment un
personnage de type kick-butt, vous savez ouais,
les enjeux sont vraiment élevés leur vie
et leur mort, donc elle sait ce qui est en jeu
et elle charge la force de sortir
et de vraiment sauver sauver des vies et  sauver le
pays ouais et je joue en tant que
femme forte était-ce que tu étais principalement la motivation pour ce
projet bien mauvais j'aime les
femmes fortes et je pense qu'au cours de ma
carrière j'ai été tu sais cogn  izant
du reflet des femmes dans les médias que ce soit
dans un film ou à la télévision ou maintenant dans ce
cas dans un jeu vidéo et c'est aussi
la première fois qu'un personnage de la série Tom
Clancy's Rainbow six e a été
trahi soit dans les livres ou le
jeu vidéo par une femme et vous savez que je vois
cela comme une nouvelle frontière, d'autant plus que
l'industrie du jeu vidéo est si grande, vous savez,
et d'après ce que j'ai découvert,
peut-être jusqu'à environ cinquante pour cent des
joueurs sont des femmes, vous savez  sont des
jeunes femmes donc je pense qu'il est approprié
et vraiment opportun que cette
diversité soit montrée tu sais que rien
n'intéresse donc j'étais vraiment ravie
qu'elles soient venues vers moi tu sais dans ce cas
hmm et euh quand tu t'as vu à travers l'
avatar pour la première fois  temps mmm qu'avez-
vous pensé du rendu c'est vrai
un avatar c'est vrai mon abbé
je n'y ai pas pensé mais oui je pensais
qu'ils avaient fait un excellent travail je pensais que
c'était vous savez très vous savez une telle
amélioration de vous savez ceux  de la
vieille  il y a peut-être un an ou deux, je pense que vous
connaissez la technologie, le look est
juste mort et si réaliste, alors
j'étais vraiment impressionné par ce qu'ils ont
pu faire, d'autant plus que vous savez
faire le mocap dans lequel vous êtes comme le néoprène
costumes et maintenant vous avez le costume ou
vous avez une calotte sur la tête avec
ces petites boules et maintenant ils ont fait
ce look, ils ont peint votre
visage à la bombe et mis des points noirs ici et
maintenant ils ont capturé  tes yeux, ton
nez, ta bouche et ton teint et ce
genre de chose et ça a l'air très très
réaliste parce que c'est ta première
expérience c'est ma vanité
Asima mec de l'industrie tu n'as pas à faire de mocap
non non non fils alors et quel était le  La
partie la plus difficile de la capture de mouvement était de jouer dans
une pièce remplie de votre capteur et de vos
caméras ou de vous déplacer comme vous le souhaitez
tout en portant un body complet ouais, nous
étions des étudiants en corps entier, mais aussi parce que
le personnage peut trouver quelque chose
ouais et pourtant comme  J'ai dit que tu connais le
les enjeux sont la vie ou la mort alors vous
voilà vêtu de cette combinaison en néoprène mais
vous savez que vous êtes très professionnel
et très sérieux et pourtant ça ressemble à
n'importe quoi mais ça a l'air fou mais ce
sont les aspects techniques qui entrent en jeu
dans la construction  ce qui
deviendra finalement le jeu ouais
bien sûr et pour certains d'entre eux, en particulier
ceux d'action, les acteurs ont besoin de plusieurs semaines de
travail de préparation vous savez et j'étais le cas
pour Rainbow six non non pas beaucoup nous avons
pris de nombreuses semaines à trop de semaines et de
mois pour  vous savez tout rassembler
mais en termes de préparation vous
connaissez le dialogue l'initiale le
dialogue initial du personnage
où elle a chargé la force vous savez dans
l'objectif ce dont ils ont besoin pour sortir
et faire c'est ce n'est pas vous connaissez un film
le script serait de cent trente
pages 115 pages et littéralement pour le
jeu, tout pourrait être sur une page au moins au
début, puis vers la fin du
processus, alors peut-être que vous connaîtrez 60
75 pages de dialogue s  o c'était un
peu différent parce que je n'ai pas
vu venir c'est comme oh vraiment mais oui
bien sûr si vous réussissez alors vous
passez au niveau suivant donc vous savez qu'il y a
quelque chose de différent qui a dit oui mais
j'ai vu celui-là venir  sympa et au cours des
dernières années, une poignée d'acteurs célèbres d'
Hollywood ont fait du mocap
pour l'industrie du jeu vidéo, vous savez, je
pense à William Dafoe et au
pitch pour au-delà de deux âmes et il y a
aussi Michael Rooker et Kevin Spacey pour l'
appel de  devoir donc ma question est ce qui se
passe c'est une tendance parmi les
acteurs horribles je ne sais pas que vous pourriez
avoir plus de quatre c'est le
début mec ouais c'est le début je
suppose qu'ils sont ils sont vous connaissez le
jeu le jeu  ou l'industrie du jeu
arrive deux acteurs et acteur le
voient c'est vous le reconnaissez comme une
grande industrie et nous arrivons nous arrivons à
bord vous savez même Spike Lee a été
casté pour NBA 2k est arrivé à un match de basket
j'en ai dirigé un  t  c'est exactement
ça et quand vous avez un projet comme celui-là,
êtes-vous ravi de le faire ou vous êtes juste
tous des enfants peut-être des jeux vidéo Je ne sais pas si
vous devez faire cela varie le frisson
parce qu'il s'agit d'un public que
vous savez construire votre public et  c'est
un public énorme alors hmm ouais je le compte il
y a un frisson a une question de ville
as-tu déjà joué à un jeux vidéo tu en
as un tu préfères bien tu sais
pac-man a gagné mais je vais jouer à celui-ci
aujourd'hui je vais jouer  doh six pouces aujourd'hui
tu ne me joues pas je suis très très bon
aucun ton smartphone non Emma écrase je fais
ouais bien
mon fils et ma fille j'ai des jumeaux de
neuf ans donc tu sais qu'ils sont vraiment
gros  c'est donc j'ai beaucoup de ceux que je
supprime et ils reviennent tout de suite j'ai
beaucoup de jeux sur mon téléphone et c'était
parce que je suis la réaction de vos
enfants quand le nouveau que vous partez
avec vous je pense que c'est un super  l'école je
suppose que nous avons pensé que maman est vraiment cool
ici surtout mes neveux tu connais et
tu connais Dieu Dieu  les enfants peu importe qui étaient
plus comme tu sais 16 à 21 ans ils sont
vraiment et tu es comme wow oh j'aurais peut-
être été nerveux je ne sais pas c'était
si grave tu sais mais ils sont tellement
excités à ce sujet d'accord dernière question
entre  2005 et 16, vous jouerez
dans un pour les films, je pense que c'est le
retour de l'angela bassett que nous connaissons
à l'époque des jours de tendance de la Chine et
Marco mix ouais toujours été ouais
attiré par vous savez des personnages vous
connaissez la force et la profondeur et vous  savoir
multidimensionnel alors oui j'espère
vraiment merci beaucoup merci merci
nous devons être le bouclier qui protège
le monde civilisé de ceux qui souhaitent
lui faire du mal, peu importe comment ou où nos
ennemis frappent, peu importe la défense
qu'ils recroquevillent  derrière l'équipe arc-en-ciel
prêt à
vous